and Plus whenever Eminem makes a
homophobic comment he comes back with
I'm for instance well I'm hoping a man
will have a cameo pass movie you know I
hope that he'll do the song at the end
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey reject nation it's Greg Alva here
Donald oh me closer tiny dancer wonder
oh nothing man they think I am at home
oh no no no I'm a Rocket Man
[Laughter]
anyway we're gonna watch this trailer
today Elton John biopic starring Taron
Egerton who you might know as Robin Hood
everyone's really looking forward to
that movie it's midnight for us right
now I'm not sure what time we're
uploading this but hey we're here to
film it anyway yeah I don't know
anything about this but here's there
know where it was like a thing until a
couple days ago yeah I know and all the
more from like you know Marv from Matt
Vaughn's company okay I don't like an
interesting I read a little blurb that
so this is mostly gonna be about like
his come up the early days of Elton
John's career you know shaking things up
so how's the John must have really gone
along with the Matthew Vaughn he's on
the Golden Circle Bennett II before we
do that I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's been following us on
those Stardust 32nd reactions for films
TV shows and trailers we do like a lot
of micro sketches on there as well as
covering a lot of things that we might
not actually cover on the youtubes it's
free to fuse it's free to follow us the
whole thing's free this shout outs free
so download and follow us the start us
app today people a lot of great users on
there and we post quite regularly so go
do that there are moments in the
rockstars life
he is trip where there was darkness
there is no you whoa and it's going to
be a wild ride
[Music]
and whoa haha face in the cheering miss
can act homie but be a long time
[Music]
cool all right cool that's not Elton
John's singing that's that sounds like
that is that Taron Egerton does that
mean I heard Rocket Man over the weekend
I'm like that doesn't sound like Elton
John unless my ears are deceiving me
maybe he did is maybe he's a triple
threat and I just didn't know about it
that's kind of cool that's that's that's
a step of confidence right there I'm
actually really intrigued by this this
is the same director did Eddie the Eagle
and feel like a lot of people forget
Internet a lot of people just think all
they did is Kingsman but it
Taron Egerton in Eddie the Eagle I think
is a dynamite performance it's something
that's very transformative you know you
might see Kingsman and go yeah charming
young guy I get it he's cool but the
eagle shows this guy can do like real
body language performances and really
transform and here you know it's the
coming up days of Elton John it's like
there's a lot of different makeup
aesthetics he's gonna be in this movie
oh yeah oh yeah I mean this has got to
be a very exciting like costume piece
like oh yeah design departments have
gotta have had a field day on this movie
because of John's like always dressed in
some crazy always very opulent and I
mean he's even got like the giant
glasses and stuff in this and I watched
some interviews with young Elton John
this afternoon and it's creepy like how
he looks like him in some of these shots
really yeah yeah and you know just to go
also catch the demeanor too cuz it's
fine it's so funny that you'd like Taron
Egerton who worked with him in Kingsman
the Golden Circle and now they're doing
this it's clearly a great relationship
it's like I want you to play me yeah
yeah yeah I want you specifically man
and then when you get older you can do
my later years it'll be great I don't
know anything about like the early
concert days I've never seen any videos
of Elton John's like early days of
performing so I don't know if this is
just some like because it's that based
on a true fantasy you know this like
ending imagery with like them floating
in the air yeah I don't know if this is
like it's a tribute to something
specific that I wouldn't mind
guys educating me on in the common boxes
let me know I like the visual Fleur to
it because you know we have Bohemian
Rhapsody coming out in just a few weeks
which is another biopic that honors the
music of a legendary icon watching the
truth hearin like wow wouldn't another
like concert like a big film but it
definitely has his own unique touches
and colors to it and looks like it's
spanning a little bit more time yeah I
mean this looks pretty exciting just
because I'm excited to see the next
stage of Taryn edgerton's career you
know like taking on more of a
performance role and I also like the
look of this as a biopic too because it
doesn't look like a straightforward you
know kind of gritty biopic in a way that
maybe the gritty is not the race but it
looks like it has a lot of imagination
you know when everybody starts floating
I got to feel like maybe there's gonna
be an element of fantasy to this that's
gonna make it unique overall yeah like
getting into sort of the mindset of
Elton John of how he's sort of visualize
everything yeah expressive quality you
told me as an active producer on this
film - right that's what I read yes
company we didn't really get like a
great look at Jamie Bell in this trailer
but I mean one of the things I learned
just this afternoon is like I always
thought Elton John was just Elton John
Bernie Taupin was the guy he wrote the
song like who wrote the lyrics and he
made the songs with like through most of
his career like of his career and so
like I got imagine that that will be a
huge part of this movie especially if
they're focusing on you know that
crucial time when he was you know really
busting onto the scene and stuff well
maybe they'll hiding the drama in here
you know I deserve credit for your
success and then they know it's a really
meeting the movies about their
friendship that generic yeah I really
hope that this film gets like really
kinetic partway through you know cuz you
got Matthew Vaughn's company producing
this as well so like really kinetic
action sequences you know like Elton
John could probably beat somebody to
death like lid of a piano Oh totally you
know like like Wilson Fisk style you
know I mean one of the genres this films
credit on on IMDB is fantasy I think
that's a very unique approach to make a
biopic stand out you know it's it's
pretty conventional to get like usually
when you get a biopic about a musician
you kind of know how the trajectory of
the
probably play out there often done and I
feel like yeah and I feel like if you're
adding an element of fantasy in there
that could allow for more than just what
accurate thing took place here what
thing could I have just read about that
will now play out here in the movie or
what thing did they tweak that's not
exactly true this allows for an actual
fictional element that I think could be
acceptable in this medium yeah cuz I
mean I feel like it would match some of
the aesthetics of Elton John's music but
it also just matched the guy himself
like he's such a big flamboyant figure
anyway and he is still with us so I feel
like to have the movie kind of reflect
him in a stylistic way as well is
actually kind of a nice idea it's crazy
because my mom loved listening to Elton
John growing up so I always heard Elton
John throughout my whole life but I
never quite appreciated him and then
listening to that greatest hits album
that diamonds dub whatever Edition that
is called this whole weekend like why
have I not been listening to more LS so
amazing I guess it was this one of those
things that like if my parents are
putting it on so I guess listen to it
but I associated like wasn't my parents
songs and this is tanaami I want to
listen to Elton John I like listen he's
health and John yeah I felt bad I like
I've been missing out on something for
so many years yeah that's always a nice
thing about any of these types of
biopics that come around is now you have
like a whole other journey to go on like
whether or not you feel anything about
the movie it's still like alright let's
jump into the catalogue yeah because I
mean he had a huge long career for sure
I mean he I think he just did it or is
on his farewell tour right now going
back to the biopic thing to I just feel
like biopic is also a genre that kind of
has a lot of conveyors so many ways you
can tell a straightforward story of
somebody's life but as a film genre it
is neat to see them expanding on it and
changing perhaps what the biopic idea
can be yeah you know I mean not to say
that it's gonna be a thousand percent
accurate in the face of that but you
know I'm curious to see how they pitch
but it looks like it'll have Elton John
stamp of approval throughout the whole
thing probably what counts most
I wonder how many of those costumes were
lent from his actual words it's a may
move it's an early start to the summer
next year but this could also be if it's
not forgotten this could be Oscar
consideration for Taron Egerton because
I mean I'm sure he's giving it his all
hey the 1997 film Rocket Man was
nominated for several Oscars so this
one's got a fallen William shows up
somewhere in there alright guys well are
you excited for Rocket Man you care more
about this more than you care about
Bohemian Rhapsody which one do you think
will be better should there be you could
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get notified
when our videos ours as you know what
people say on YouTube and check us out
in the Stardust app download it follows
first link in the description box good
day hey people